sobem 20 e hoje vou ensinar como fazer
uma pistola e só de papel muito fácil e
muito forte que vocês depois podem
comprovar eles nos testes mas agora
vamos ter como sala com segurança vão
precisar de obras por pressão e quando
dispararem muitos parentes assim eu sei
que ajuda para mirar mas pode ser
perigoso um elástico sobrou depois vai
preparado para a vossa cara quer por
agente vocês deixem esta distância sobre
manter tudo bem vai fazer aqui alguma
coisa mas vocês vão ficar ok então é
isso agora vamos aos testes pois o
tutorial passo páscoa
então vamos lá pessoal o primeiro tem
que rolar uma folha com se fosse uma
rifa é que ela das feiras
caso vocês não conseguiu voar um papel
com de ser eu vou deixar um link de
inscrição no ensino a fazer isso mais
ligar passa para depois fazerem esta
rifa tem que rolar não foi a volta de
modo a fazer um tubo em forma para isso
vocês apertem bem na hora de voar
aprenda com fita com vai ser em 3 lugar
suas extremidades e no centro
para finalizar o tubinho é salvar um
pedaço grande porto um lado ou outro
aqui vamos ter de cortar um pedaço
contou centros e 6 pudéssemos com cinco
centímetros e bom claro desta maneira se
micro alimentar para fazer empunhadura
da arma tem uma folha normal
deste modo fazer um quadrado corta um
retângulo e em roma outra parte mais
fina e mais frágil e à distância uma
dobra de forma rápida uma super cola
cola viva ficou muito plástico e ficando
muito que fazer a abertura caso vocês
sejam crianças e um adulto com certeza
que não vai importar de entrar nessa
volta brincadeira aqui uns a escola
rápida também está cotado a 45 graus e
vou encaixar nessa parte dele
cortem o chefe
esta partida é pré perdedor da arma e
vejam como é que funciona quando em puro
futebol e saem depois vou entrar num
cano que esta parte aqui que eu já abri
a mesma coisa que vocês viram a segundos
atrás caí só encaixar uma abertura na
outra e colar
deixamos cara virou um contrário e põe
cola no outro lado conseguir ver que só
colar a parte perdedora a parte do cano
qualquer vendedor explica henrique tem
quatro centímetros mas é mais ou menos
opcional até por ter mais com menos e
vou fazer aqui um quilo difícil para pôr
as balas
se quiserem podem não fazer e em vez de
pôr pelo bloquinho é só retirar a parte
laranja em pôr as balas e no inter
direto no carregador
agora só falta a forçar a arma pra ficar
mais resistente e depois fazer o que
estão aqui é bastante simples mas muito
eficaz em termos de resistência
nesta parte abusem de cola aqui depois
vai ficar lá preso elástico querem é
chato em uma rifa desta maneira quem
parte mais frágil e contornem a partida
empunhadura da água do lugar não tenho
pressa vai ficar tudo ser feito
portanto aqui como é óbvio vocês têm que
rolar parte a parte
quanto mais cola usar melhor mais de 70
vossa arma vai ficar talvez não tenham
pressa
esperem que acontecer para rolar mais
uma para satisfazer mais uma rifa
daquela masculina o site the dog não faz
um quadrado corta um chefe em roll que
vai servir para fazer o pistão da arma
tem que ser o elemento mais fininho que
reiniciar o quê serviu para referência
para outubro ok ok as marcações caso
você não tenha percebido muito bem é só
por causa e ver do galinho aí
agora eu vou colar com fita qualquer eu
e dois elásticos agora oscilado vocês
pois vem com sua força e existência da
arma se dá por mais ou não
não podia faltar ali cola para diminuir
o atrito e ele também porque porque o
que ela trabalha basicamente o pistão
button e então vai homologar não tiver
cola se vocês quiserem cola vai ficar
muito mais resistente e vai aguentar
muito muito mais tempo aqui e pronto
agora só quer ganhar
se você não tiver ele é que o edifício
terá para laranja e colocar direto do
tubo e aí estão vendo aqui funcionamento
vocês carregam mexem aquela parte
laranja foi entrar uma bala ou mais e
por isso vou carregar no gatilho e
esperar
tudo pronto só os carros o fim eu espero
que tenham gostado se vocês quiserem
ajudar o canal só deixaria com league e
se inscreva para acompanhar os próximos
dias caso não seja o skate é isso do
marketing ao tre